let's talk about amazon.com Donald Trump
has been going after amazon.com and I'm
pretty worried about his attack for a
few reasons none of which are I just
love amazon.com and think they should be
exempt from criticism so number one it's
yet another attack on the media actually
because what Trump really is attacking
when he attacks amazon.com is the
Washington Post which is owned by Amazon
founder Jeff Bezos that's number one
they've been doing very good
investigative reporting on Trump Trump
hates it so it's really an attack on the
Washington Post more than it is an
attack on Amazon but let's for a moment
take the attack at face value sort of as
an attack on an individual business
which is concerning when the president
starts attacking one particular business
and let's evaluate the attack on his
merit on its merits and you will very
quickly see that Trump's attack
basically falls flat and it is more of
the hypocrisy that we've grown
accustomed to Trump's big argument
against Amazon is that Amazon doesn't
pay taxes on online shipments in a lot
of the United States here's just one
example of when Trump has brought this
up this is from Trump's own Twitter
account where Trump said I have stated
my concerns with Amazon long before the
election why election is capitalized we
will never know but it is sweet unlike
others they pay little or no taxes to
state and local governments use our
postal system as their delivery boy also
just random capitalization causing
tremendous loss to the United States and
are putting many thousands of retailers
out of business
hypocrisy number one is that if what
Amazon is doing is legal which it is
it's the same thing Trump bragged about
doing during debates with Hillary
Clinton right I'm sure you remember this
moment where Hillary Clinton said we
haven't seen his tax returns he probably
is paying very little or no taxes we
don't know and Trump said that makes me
smart so why is it okay for Trump to use
any legal means available to avoid
taxation but it's not okay for Amazon to
do the exact same thing but layer two of
the hypocrisy is that we've learned that
Trump's own online store Trump store.com
pays online taxes in just two states
even though Amazon actually pays for
taxes for online sales in 45 out of 50
states what Trump is slamming amaz
for doing his own online store does to
an even worse degree but the real
problem here is that if you really think
the problem is businesses not paying
taxes why didn't the tax plan he
supported do something about that
instead of exempting the first 20
percent of a business's pass-through
income from taxation altogether lower
the corporate tax rate and lower taxes
on the rich like he just had an
opportunity to deal with this problem
put aside the personal hypocrisy
why didn't he deal with it with his own
tax plan if this is such an issue as he
played zero role in writing it why
there's that like he was just the pen
yes and that's the thing like so much
this is another example of us putting
giving credit and responsibility to the
president in a place where it all
belongs on Congress sure so that's why I
mean he was just the only reason that
Congress is even dealing with him is
because he's willing to sign their stuff
into law absolutely but also he's a
giant hypocrite and by the way it's not
just Amazon right like there's a ton of
companies that do this exact same thing
and I actually am concerned when the
president basically takes a personal
vendetta out on one company Amazon
doesn't need our defense right Amazon
doesn't need us to come and defend them
for whatever business practices we can
be critical for whatever else Amazon is
not the only company that does this it's
also not about the principle - it's
totally personal yes because Jeff Bezos
has the net worth of what like a hundred
billion dollars yeah we're a trump at
best has ten billion so he think he's
jealous
I think it's total jealousy absolutely
maybe there is an element what we can be
sure of is that none of the possible
right reasons for this criticism are
actually what underlies the criticism
it's either personal jealousy a vendetta
the typical double standards and just
sort of the inability to accept what is
pretty good critical reporting from the
Washington Post on a lot of issues about
the things that Trump has been doing
I don't know how worried you are about
the singling out of individual
businesses in this way but I think it's
terrible precedent
aside from Amazon needing anybody to go
and defend them which they don't well I
mean I think so much of this Trump
administration is setting terrible
precedent in so many ways but I'm
getting to the point now after a year
and a half of this when Trump says
anything I'm just tuning it out yeah
it's just gotten to that point so I
think what's going to happen here is
eventually
Jesus is gonna have enough he's gonna go
and say hello to Trump shake his hand
and trumple tweet that oh he is the
nicest man he's a really fine guy yeah
amazing what he's been able to do with
amazon.com exactly it's all it's gonna
take he just wants to be friends like
did you notice that our China policy is
changing now that he considers the head
of China to be his friend yeah and
that's it's actually really concerning
because other countries if they can't
really know what the Trump policy is
going to be or the policy of the u.s. in
relation to them that really hampers
their ability to do anything and that's
a whole other geopolitical concern that
I'm sure will talk but it works with
companies - yeah oh absolutely it's the
same thing it's just a childish man who
wants everyone to like him and right now
he perceives through the Washington Post
that Jeff Bezos doesn't against him yeah
and so all it's gonna take is a
handshake yeah I'm waiting for it'll be
over very very soon and then we'll never
hear again about Amazon's tax practices
from Trump
we'll take a break we will talk about
tariffs coming up next this episode of
the show is made possible in part by
zipper that's ZPE
our zipper is designing a global
decentralized peer-to-peer alliance
through which companies can provide
secure global and diversified investment
portfolios to minimize risk zippers
initial coin offering for their new
cryptocurrency starts April 16th zippers
goal is to use smart contract technology
to provide a revolutionary method of
funding transactions between borrowers
and lenders worldwide and one of the
best potential benefits would be zippers
ability to allow people with no credit
to borrow currency through alternative
forms of verifying creditworthiness on
the zipper blockchain if you're watching
this on youtube look in the description
for a link to their website and links to
information about their airdrop and
bounty program this is not financial
advice and of course everyone should do
their own research before spending money
anywhere